Voiceover:Sort the drawings according
to the equation that correctly describes
the relationship between
the vectors drawn.
An equation may have any number of cards,
and cards with no corresponding equation
should be left unsorted.
Let's see what they're talking about here.
Right over here, they have depicted,
let's see, they're adding
vector A to vector B.
We see that, because vector B's tail
is at the head of vector A.
They're adding vector A to vector B.
If you connect the tail of vector A
to the head of Vector B,
you get vector C.
They're really showing that
vector A plus vector B
is equal to vector C.
Let's see if we can find that.
A is showing that vectors A+B,
vector A plus vector B
is equal to vector C.
Let's look at the second choice.
This choice, right over here is showing
that vector B plus vector
C is equal to vector A.
So B+C is equal to A.
That is this choice, right over here.
Diagram or graph B is showing us
that vector B plus vector
C is equal to vector A.
Now let's look at this
choice, right over here.
This is showing us that B+A is equal to C.
It doesn't matter which
way you order them.
The way they've set it up,
this is B+A is equal to C.
That is not one of the choices,
but you could, whether you're doing A+B,
or B+A, it's going to be the same thing.
I'm gonna throw it into this category,
right over here.
This is the same thing as A+B.
Instead of putting the
tail of B at the head of A,
they just put the tail
of A at the head of B.
It doesn't matter what order
you are adding those two vectors.
You're still going to
get the same, vector C.
Finally, this right over here,
this is C+A is equal to B.
This is C+A or A+C is equal to B.
It doesn't matter if we
do vector A plus vector C
or vector C plus vector A.
Let's just make sure that
we've got all of these right, and we have.